yeah hello and welcome to this video
coverage form and the second game of the
World Championship match currently held
in New York yeah we have kyle aachen
playing white so let's see what happens
in Game two interesting question what
would be the first move and clanking
goes with e4 which is his main move
basically from when he was a little kid
but in recent years he has been a bit
more versatile with white playing d4c
490 of 3 so and it wasn't at all clear I
think nowadays and most players are very
flexible and they adapt to what they
expect from their opponent so if they
let's say find a particularly great idea
and let's say see for opening he might
play c4 just to get this little thing in
that they found so people are less
principled with a couple of lines that
they continue to play but the form is
basically yeah going back to the roots
of Iraqi aachen yo cousin goes e5
unsurprisingly his assistance is almost
exclusive answer when he is facing his
peers he sometimes face a place other
stuff when he plays Rico opponents I'm
on to get his surprise and once in a
while but in the world championship that
you expect in five um yeah and we got
them really Lopez um in the ICC
commentary there was some talk people
expected move default for the Scotch
opening yes yeah the Scotch has been
played back a shocking once in a while
and he has some nip ami achi on his team
was a Squatch expert so that was a
possibility of it this is still the main
the main choice let's say the Reno past
um okay a six this is not a surprise but
Carson owns chooses a 6 or 9 f six for
the building and according to i will
probably opponent or mood or whatever
so here it goes a 60 this is perfectly
normal and yeah Bishop e7 is the start
of the absolute Mainliner of the room
here white has some two main choices the
rookie one that's a traditional main
line or d3 which is maybe the modern
mainline rookie one and place or
potentially place into into this
variation where black has the marshal
attack available here this is still a
headache for white players and they seek
for ways to avoid this marshal attack on
marshall gamble and d3 is one of those
one of those possibilities yeah
currently as I said it's almost the main
line on it but on the top level so d6
played here by Carson white now has to
be aware that night a5 is a threat here
winning or no winning as strong words
been getting the the riddle pass Bishop
so white has to do something about it
you should not play let's say something
like Age 3 and then 95 will get this
important piece that is on a good
diagonal black gets the bishop am and
it's quite happy here so basically only
mu c RC 3 a 3 those kind of moves and a
3 is played by kayaking this is one of
the ideas of the early d3 that you're
still flexible here with those moves a
three counts cancelled and now nine to
33 and yeah this is one of the points
here that this is the possibility and
the idea is that in some cases white is
able to put a knight on d5 which makes
them yeah some situations a bit awkward
for black for example I'm not saying
that this is a bad move now we should be
six I just want to want to show the IDM
if you have a situation like then white
could play this and it's not so clear
what black should do now yeah you cannot
take with the night due to the fork and
if the
sorry if the bishop takes this is
probably not all that great yeah this
night is offside okay alternatively it
could go back with why this quite happy
here with this situation so there is a
point to the night mover it can
sometimes very effectively go to d5 yeah
council place 95 here Bishop a to this
bishop has to be preserved and now be
should be six yeah this is a difference
now now 95 is far less of an of an
option let's same because here black can
take on d5 and will not give up the
bishop pair something like this is
probably quite okay so d4 was played
here by kayaking right by the way can
take on e6 that's possible but not only
um this kind of pawn structure is viewed
as okay for black yeah it is possible
though it has been played in Grand
Master games yeah he played d for this
is a more recent idea just to strike in
the center while the night is them yeah
out out on the air chair um takes on a
two and rook takes looks a bit funny but
then I look will return to a one pretty
soon um this is actually the first
little interesting situation here in the
game there's been a game in June this
year between to Parliament cards a rapid
game where our cards are played the move
Knight to c6 and after d5 went back to
the eighth looks a bit weird but the
night is actually better placed in the
future then on a five are here later c6
will come and the spawn center will be
attacked um cards and ultimately won
that game and rapid chess against apart
of however you can argue that this is
maybe not the best continuation knight
c6 and but rather the move that he
played in the game now get the group to
e8 and this sir seems to be very ok for
black yeah the thing is it looks like a
five is
is unattended but white cannot take this
pawn in any good way like here if white
takes on d 8 yeah black yeah we can
actually take with the bishop if you
want but this is this is easily possible
as this is not upon that white can hang
on for long and this is now hanging has
to go back and black well get this and
here in a position like this of course
it's rather black who's better it's just
more active and why does a little bit
weirdly placed here with the rukon a two
and then why can also take the
immediately but it's the same story the
bishop will move you can go to f8 or d6
let's say to f8 and it's impossible to
to hold this something like this it's
quite awkward you will always get this
porn back so he did not have to cover a
fight with 96 yeah and now it's the
Hawkins turn to show something yeah he
plays rook to a one this is probably
unavoidable in the long run the look is
just too weird on a tune and now night
see for this is Carlton's point he
delayed the night move and now we can
actually go to c4 which is interesting
because the night I think has a pretty
good spot on b6 looking at a critical
square d 5 and yeah what did kayaking do
now rookie one centralized and car don't
let the move rook c8 that was not the
only movie also had other other options
and a move like c5 for example of c6
also comes to mind but rook c8 is a very
good flexible move yeah it keeps many
options open a move that's quite typical
of the reasons this bishop move but
after possible Bishop g5 the spin is a
bit awkward so he wanted too late to
delay that probably as well so it's a
very good flexible move those small
little details they really are what's
going on in a
like that on the surface not much
happens but um the most of the best
players they often just a little bit
more precise than the moves of of a
normal player i can easily let's say
this kind of position could easily
happen in my games with black as i am
the same the same line but i can easily
imagine that I would play we should fade
or something I'll get into slight
problems and they are the best players
in the world they are just a little bit
more precise about it yeah group c 8 and
now question is what can why to do in
this position he decided to play the
move h3 this is something that of course
kind of belongs in too many rule of pest
positions and sometimes to avoid the pin
but this is not not relevant anymore and
here h3 was played probably too yeah to
maybe make Bishop e3 um yeah a little
bit less vulnerable to let you fall to
meet smooth slightly mysterious unless
you really didn't know what to do and I
mean you cannot be three there's nothing
wrong with that and now continue from
here I don't know if h3 is really am a
necessary move and all in all I think
that black is quite funny after the
trade of the landscape Bishop and I
think you should be okay um yeah well h3
was played age six typical move here to
maybe allow Bishop f82 to do this
without Bishop g5 being an issue yeah
and now we rehab this position yeah calc
an official v2 we should aid so we have
all those kind of schematic moves in and
now it's time for y2 to make some kind
of decision what to do and yeah I also
bit surprised to see a guy Atkins move
now because this is basically the same
as giving up with the fight for any any
sort of
advantage and he doubt took only five
what he did and usually this is viewed
as a concession trading the dc4 against
city six pawn it it really leads to
basically nothing what he could have
done is to just keep the tension with
moves like they're not that many
actually probably a queen or a community
to or queen d3 one of those and just
then see what happens I mean probably
it's an equal position but um it is a
little bit more play left on the board I
don't know what black would do we can
think about see 5 or player evading
moves like this let's get those c6 I
mean black is pretty flexible here but
that would be the way to to play that
same after the trade this position is
very symmetrical as it's quite quite
obvious and it's very difficult typical
to get anything going here a 92 bringing
the night over the night was not well
placed on c3 looking at protected square
so this is an understandable decision um
cousin 20a he actually already could
have taken only fire that was there was
nothing wrong with that but maybe my
cousin wasn't pretty wasn't overly
concerned you can prob with this
position and maybe just wanted to play
on in a little bit and see what happens
yeah 9bg seven and a night on b6 now
it's not that greater with the ones here
you'd rather wants to go here since why
before was played by white and here yeah
he already c5 was possible to kill and
kill the game off but it's it just
trades down two to nothing the way it
went here c5 was played and now we got
mass exchanges yeah you don't need to be
a participant in this match too
see that nothing happens the end they
have this i don't know i think they only
do did this once and then then agree to
a draw yeah so this game was arguably
even less interesting than the first one
but yeah this is mostly due to a kayak
ins play a little bit if you take on e5
and so on it's just not going to win
again yeah I hope things get more
interesting in the in the next in the
next game third game and Carlton has
wide again thanks for watching guys